hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd cosmetics
skin care nerd and today i'm talking
about sustainability sustainability and
environmental impact is a huge topic
everywhere these days and it's always
tricky to talk about it's obviously
something that the vast majority of us
care a lot about but a lot of companies
are approaching it in a way that's easy
to market but doesn't make a lot of
scientific sense there's a ton of green
washing going on and you'll have seen me
debunk green washing myths before in my
videos and on instagram today i'm going
to be talking about a brand that i think
are approaching sustainability in a
really holistic innovative and
transparent way emma lewisham this video
is sponsored by emma lotion they gave me
early access to information about their
innovations but as always these are my
genuine opinions as we go through it all
hopefully you'll see why i decided to
work with them emma lotion is a high-end
natural skincare brand from new zealand
i personally don't really care if the
products i use are natural or synthetic
as long as they work well and emolution
products do work really well which i'll
talk about a bit later but first let's
talk about the really cool work they've
been doing in sustainability i think
there's this passion in how the beauty
industry tends to do sustainability
brands often point to one small thing
they're doing and claim to be
sustainable and then that seems to be it
they tell you nothing about the rest of
their business and a lot of the time
that one thing seems to be
environmentally friendly at first but
then isn't actually that good when you
look deeper into it emma lewisham
approached sustainability in a much more
holistic way with a carbon positive
circular design business model let's
start with carbon positive this is kind
of confusing carbon positive carbon
negative and climate positive all pretty
much mean the same thing more greenhouse
gases are being removed than being
emitted generally this is done by the
business measuring their emissions and
then offsetting them by investing in
projects that remove greenhouse gases
from the atmosphere offsets can be
controversial and misleading sometimes
offsets can act like a license for
businesses to keep polluting as much as
they want as long as they pay a small
fee and then still look environmentally
friendly and it's impossible to offset
all of our current emissions reductions
still have to happen emolution make it
clear that reducing emissions is their
primary focus here they aim to
eventually have nothing left to offset
they are the first business to be
certified climate positive by toyota and
varicare they're a new zealand
government-owned science-led
environmental organization the way this
certification works is very
comprehensive and quantitative to be
certified climate positive a business
needs to firstly measure all their
direct and indirect emissions across
their value chain this obviously
includes all the emissions produced when
they're consuming energy to make their
products but also for producing and
transporting raw materials transporting
the finished products to customers and
stores making the product packaging and
dealing with the packaging after the
products being used the company has to
commit to reducing their missions to
line up with the paris agreement goals
this includes working with suppliers to
reduce emissions outside of the
company's direct control these supply
chain emissions are often many times
higher than the company's direct
operational emissions their progress
gets monitored every third year to make
sure this is a continued effort the
company offsets the remainder plus at
least 25
then finally the company has to invest
in projects that help the wider sector
or society decarbonize make a just
transition or adapt to climate change
impacts and this is set at at least 75
percent of the offset amount
unsurprisingly there are lots of
different strategies that emilucian used
to get to this stage and any of them
would probably make a great marketing
story on their own for example they use
100 renewable energy in manufacturing
their products and their boxes as well
as powering their offices every product
has a carbon emission score they plan to
halve these by 2023 and have them at
virtually zero by 2030. the biggest
piece of the pie though is packaging
here's where the circular model comes in
packaging is the biggest source of
carbon emissions in the beauty industry
it accounts for an estimated 70
on top of this there's the waste issue
the beauty industry uses a lot of highly
complex components in packaging because
a lot of formulas especially highly
active formulas are unstable without
things like pumps and opaque containers
but this means a lot of it is too
expensive to recycle and if you just
chuck it in your normal recycling bin it
ends up in landfill anyway the result is
that most beauty packaging isn't
recycled even if it claims to be 100
recyclable to solve these issues emma
lotion have created their own circular
system this new packaging produces 74
less emissions than their old single-use
packaging all of their products are
refillable most products come in jars
there are three airless pump jars and
one regular jar all of these use
refillable pods that slot into a base
jar on top which are designed to be used
over and over the pods are made from
post-consumer recycled plastic so it
financially supports the recycling of
other containers the rest of the
products come in glass bottles that are
refilled with pouches that means that
you still get the benefits of glass
packaging but without having to ship
that heavy fragile container back and
forth as many times that means less
emissions and lower risk of product loss
the circular part of this is that emma
lotion makes that back all of their
packaging at no cost to their customers
through the emma lujan beauty circle
which is available worldwide once you
collect enough empty containers to make
the shipping emissions worth it you mail
them back to emma lotion free of charge
recycling is the last option it requires
more energy than reusing when a
container can't be used again emma
lotion pay to have a recycle through
terracycle a specialty recycler
currently 79 of their packaging can be
sterilized and refilled only the pouches
can't and these are recycled this whole
system is really cool and well thought
out but i think the thing that impressed
me the most about this is that emma
lotion are making all the intellectual
property associated with it available
publicly this is so other brands can
take advantage of their investment
especially smaller brands which wouldn't
have the financial ability to switch to
more sustainable practices otherwise
this includes their sterilizing
processes how they deal with recycling
and returns packaging supply info take
back procedures carbon calculation
guides as well as the designs for their
refillable packaging each of their molds
cost ten thousand dollars to develop so
it's not a cheap process a lot of things
in the beauty industry are kept very
secret so this is really unusual and i
think it really speaks to their real
commitment to sustainability not just
for marketing their own products as
better than their competitors but to
actually make a real change in how the
beauty industry works they've also been
recently endorsed by dr jane goodall the
chimpanzee researcher and
environmentalist on to the products i've
mentioned this a few times before one of
the big issues with eco-friendly brands
is that a lot of the time the products
don't work as well as other products on
the market and this is especially the
case with products that only use natural
ingredients and if the products don't
work well people don't buy them which
means they end up having a limited
environmental impact because they just
can't get any market share but emma
lewisham have cult status products even
without that environmental aspect
they've also hired an independent
testing lab to perform in vitro lab
studies on cells as well as clinical
studies on actual human skin to make
sure their products are effective the
details are on their website a side note
emma lotion did start off as a brand
that marketed themselves as clean but
they've changed their focus radically
partly because they watched my content i
was reluctant to work with them at first
because of their clean marketing even
though their environmental initiatives
and their products sound really cool but
i think they're genuinely trying to fix
that part of their marketing every time
i go to their website i see less and
less stuff that i have an issue with
emma lotion are best known for their
highly active natural products their
most famous product is probably the skin
reset this is a brightening serum for
people with hyperpigmentation issues it
has the super popular ingredient
niacinamide or vitamin b3 as well as a
patient stem cell extract that's been
found to have really interesting
activity in vitro there are also a bunch
of hydrating ingredients like prickly
pear and sea buckthorn oil edelweiss
extract and hyaluronic acid skin reset
was developed when emma was looking for
an alternative to hydroquinone to use
when trying for a baby hydroquinone
isn't recommended when you're pregnant
skin resets being tested on melanocyte
cells against nine other competitor
serums it was the only one that was
found to be active but without also
killing the cells obviously the way that
products work on your skin isn't the
same as how they work on cells in a dish
but it's a promising sign skin reset has
also been tested on people's skin after
12 weeks 88 of participants said they
noticed no new hyperpigmentation 77
rated it as effective at reducing
hyperpigmentation the big reason skim
reset is so popular is that it's really
gentle while still being effective this
is my favorite product from the range i
get a lot of pigment after i have acne
and almost every brightening serum i
have is irritating apart from my
niacinamide products this has
niacinamide with a bunch of other stuff
as well and i don't need to use a
moisturizer with it emma lotion's other
really famous product is the
supernatural 72 hour cream this is an
intensely hydrating night cream with
anti-aging actives that help with skin
firming and texture the star anti-aging
ingredients are pecutial and ellaria
esculenta seaweed extract much like with
skin reset these don't cause as much
irritation and sensitivity as a lot of
other anti-aging actives tend to do and
again there are lots of other really
moisturizing ingredients too like
saccharide isomerate a super effective
humectant that holds onto water and
gives skin prolonged 72-hour hydration
it shows up in a lot of emma lotion
products again supernatural outperforms
a lot of leading luxury anti-aging skin
care products in in vitro cell studies
and it has impressive clinical results
as well i really enjoyed this cream over
winter it has a really rich texture that
spreads over skin easily so you don't
need a lot to hydrate skin really well
there's also the supernatural face oil
this has anti-aging plant ingredients
like pecutial and swertia chirata
extract they're in a really luxurious
old base that's full of linoleic acid
from rosehip oil and kalahari melon oil
there's also the illuminating brighten
your day cream this has plant extracts
with vitamin c and ahas yes you can use
hydroxy acids during the day as well as
hydrating saccharide isomerate and
ceramides the illuminating exfoliant is
a creamy hydrating washoff product with
jojoba wax beads and hydroxy acids the
illuminating oil cleanser is lovely and
rich and melts away makeup really easily
skin shield is an spf 30 zinc oxide
sunscreen unfortunately like most other
zinc oxide products there is a slight
white cast with this otherwise it's
really nice it has a moisturizing
texture and lots of active and hydrating
ingredients the products are all really
luxurious they do have a botanical base
fragrance which is a bit on the stronger
side pretty typical strength for natural
skin care but if you're used to more
clinical brands then it might be a bit
of a change so overall i'm really
impressed with this system i think
emmeloshim have done a lot of amazing
work in developing natural skincare
that's really effective and then also
this incredible carbon positive business
model the refillable packaging and the
systems for making sure customers can
easily complete the circle is really
well thought out a lot of circular
systems and beauty fail because that
link is missing it needs to be as easy
as possible for consumers to do their
part and on top of that sharing the ip
as well is just really fantastic there's
so much that's not transparent in the
beauty industry it's really hard to work
out what brands could or should be doing
especially for small companies that are
just starting out i think a lot of us
are getting pretty frustrated with how
the beauty industry tends to claim as
being environmentally friendly by
pointing to small isolated actions that
aren't particularly well thought out or
evidence-based but i think emma lotion
is a good example of how a beauty brand
can operate differently and i hope other
brands can take inspiration from this
and re-examine how they run their
operations i've linked a bunch of
resources about emma lotion's products
and systems below i've also got more
info on the carbon positive
certification like subscribe
notification bell follow me on instagram
check out my blog and i'll see you next
time to nerd out more